are we already sweating and all ready to
shovel mm-hmm Showtime no no carbon is
great something you don't know no you
know your life is different now
this video is exactly what it's titled
the Billboard Music Awards yes they
happened over the weekend
yes I'm late to the game but you can't
play the game if you don't show up to
the game so better late been pregnant
you've got a sports and a science lesson
so you're welcome that's of you the
record sessions of the Billboard Music
Awards and as all can be asked to
fashion review videos I will likely and
definitely not review someone you
probably want to be too so eat [ __ ] I
mean please forgive me Judah Jackson Wow
the clock struck midnight and Cinderella
turning back into her regular gap ad so
we got Fly Girl hair paints her white
t-shirt 90's cowboy girl beau and kids
and yet up from the waist down
you're a whole dang food pyramid of
fashion palsy whoa
you look different you look like Julia
Louie Dreyfus and Avril Lavigne face
smash you also look like a Pirates wife
that's going to prom in the eighties and
your shoes look like you're wearing a
super classy home tracking device ankle
prison bracelets a very cute oh oh this
is Mila Kunis and I had no idea at first
are you wearing clip in bags I have
given myself grow bags and also used to
own a pair of clipping bags until I
realized it's not a cute like prop to
have in the house at all time but either
like you you like you shop at the dead
bunny the fancy section of the Dead not
likely clearance racks which is the only
place I shopped when I went to the damn
you know what the Deb is probably most
of you don't but if you do leave a
comment down below if you don't know the
Deb is like a Charlotte Russe had like a
terrible younger angsty trashy
stepsister not something to do with
trash you know no you look like a bear
elegant cocktail waitress cute Taylor
Swift oh my gosh this is beautiful
he's a
you're floating doing a Grecian goddess
also you look like you've aged backwards
I feel like this is back when you have
the ring like hair you look what how did
you do this because you went into
hibernation for three months
uh-huh I'm sure you figured out time
travel it was like you're looking at the
camera like yeah I know the Trojans are
over there fighting for me
who wouldn't Barton's Trojans who did
Helen of Troy face that launched a
thousand ships and now it's just like a
Rolodex of random in my head that's what
I call my brain yeah Alison Brie oh very
sexy very Victoria's Secret lingerie
it needs cow waxer a shower it's like
soft and sexy edgy and sweet like when I
convince myself that my body can handle
ice cream it tastes delicious and then
it makes my body do bad things cute Tara
Sierra Sierra co-op see Wow Tara's like
the body that's just just got walk
around naked just be naked you like you
took the tool from the background of
like a prom photo set up and you just
wrap it around you and complain me you
really did it cute Camela kamijo oh
there's a lot of black and white themes
going on here very like elegant cocktail
attire up top and then someone tp'ed the
lower half of you textural una you
Jennifer Lopez JLo what you also aged
not you don't age I love this color on
you it looks absolutely beautiful
peaking of textural wow you got
snakeskin and the velvet snakeskin is
like a lara croft kind of like a
modern-day makeover from the guys from
queer i yeah yeah John Legend just
always look so happy to be there your
aesthetic is just chill as [ __ ]
I love a good mixture of patterns plus
you look classy and like maybe you're
going to a polo match or you're gonna
play golf after the event or you look at
them they're elegant like poker dealer
up top you Nick Jonas more like Joe
nasty you nasty with these where'd you
get what I mean
gun control also what happened to your
other suspender did you hoped out of it
didn't you before
- the carpet that's okay still one does
the job cute - yeah oh you look like
Coachella Barbie you look like a
dreamcatcher you Haley Baldwin why do
you look so sad because you're so
beautiful
this is absolutely stunning why are you
so grumpy good night
straightline mouth upside down then
it'll still be straight this is
beautiful
good job looks like your vagina is
eating your dress cute bebe Rexha whoa
what were you shuffling your feet down
that red carpet cuz someone's got some
static but I like it you Tyra Banks not
enough shuffling those feet on this red
carpet Tyra guy keep up with bebe it's
still very elegant very cute ones doing
this like very gothic eighties vamp
thing I like it okay this says it's
Gray's that mayor Morris and Michael
Trey wore thought this looks like some
matrix dimension Saved by the Bell cast
right now what AC slander screech Kelly
and Zack yeah Christina Aguilera this is
like you took a giant that's also
happens to be like a stockbrokers pants
and you just put your body in one leg of
it and wrap the belt around and then let
the other leg draper's a cake train
kidding grace van der Waal she's
becoming well I'm not becoming she is my
new style icon she's so cool I wish I
could wear this outfit every single day
it's like the monopoly man got like
Freaky Friday into just an over a
teenager cute Demi Lovato Wow you took a
scarf from my stepmoms closet and made
it into your dress and I think it's
great very sexy cute Mason Ramsey the
yodeling kid this makes me uncomfortable
for some reason and I'd like to move
forward in this review video cute du
liebe is I hate you saying I don't know
but she seems very cool and this looks
absolutely stunning everyone's got a
bear like a tease esque bomb to it it's
the shoulder past looks like you found
it in like a goodwill but a really good
well QG gorgeous always looks goddamn
gorgeous you think you just got out of a
pool through dress on let your hair dry
naturally and I'm like hi I'm effortless
by like a sexy baby carrot yeah Patrick
stop oh my god this
is incredible Patrick always looks
fantastic on any carpet but this is this
look is so attractive I feel like I've
been deflowered dude
Frankie Grande always looks amazing
always looks fun always looks like he's
having the best goddamn time 118 less
pants more fun that could be taken
incredibly wrong
Jordan moon shoes type of thing going on
and then some like hot pants in case you
gotta you know do the Tour de France
after the award show and then you got
like a very good Clark
esque upper body and then like pink hair
like the singer pink but it's a
physically beautiful combination and I
love it yeah okay there we go there is
my review of the red carpet fashions at
the Billboard Music Awards again I know
I have definitely left out people you
wanted me to talk about I'm very sorry
let me know in the comments down below
if who your favorite would and that's it
make sure you subscribe to this youtube
channel if you haven't already cuz i'm
still making videos hit that Bell
notification so that you find out when
they go up because between you and me I
don't even know these days other than
that I don't know
BTS Wow I don't want to say anything
that could be offensive BTS fans are
very intense they have much respect as
to I for this group but I do want to say
that they look fantastic I want all of
their outfits they look like the many
faces of one singular dad going through
a little bit of a crisis in a cool way